CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE BRIEFING
AT THE WHITE HOUSE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYING THE
COUNTRY HAS PASSED THE PEAK OF
THE PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE NEW INFORMATION TONIGHT
TO HER JOHN ROBERTS ASK ABOUT
THE ORIGINS OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
MULTIPLE SOURCES SAY THIS MAY BE
THE COSTLIEST GOVERNMENT
COVER-UP OF ALL TIME BY CHINA.
YOU HEARD THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
JOINT CHIEFS ASK ABOUT OUTCOME
OF THE INTELLIGENCE WAS
INCONCLUSIVE BUT THERE IS A
GROWING BELIEF THAT THE COVID-19
VIRUS ORIGINATED IN THE WUHAN
LAB, NOT AS A BIO WEAPON BUT AS
CHINA’S EFFORT TO FIND AND DEAL
WITH VIRUSES TO SHOW THE WORLD
IT WAS AS GOOD OR BETTER THAN
THE U.S. ON THAT FRONT.
IT’S BELIEVED THE VIRUS WAS BACK
TO HUMAN, HUMAN TO HUMAN PATIENT
ZERO, WENT TO THE POPULATION OF
WUHAN AND THE VIRUS SPREAD FROM
THERE.
CHINA MOVED QUICKLY TO SHUT DOWN
TRAVEL DOMESTICALLY FROM WUHAN
TO THE REST OF CHINA BUT DID NOT
IMMEDIATELY STOP INTERNATIONAL
FLIGHTS FROM WUHAN.
THE SOURCES SAY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION WAS COMPLICIT FROM
THE BEGINNING HELPING CHINA
COVER ITS TRACKS AND THAT IS
WHERE WE BEGIN TONIGHT.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF.
IF YOU ASKED ABOUT THIS
REPORTING TONIGHT AND GOT
SOMETHING FROM THE PRESIDENT AND
PART OF THE REASON WHY THE
PRESIDENT THIS COMING DOWN SO
HARD ON THE W.H.O.
>> President Trump: THERE
CERTAINLY HAS BEEN A CHANGE OF
TONE FROM BACK IN FEBRUARY WHEN
THE PRESIDENT DESCRIBED THE
W.H.O. AS SOME OF THE BEST AND
THE BRIGHTEST AS CLEARLY THIS
INFORMATION BEGINS TO DEVELOP,
THE PRESIDENT IS CHANGING HIS
MIND NOT ONLY ABOUT THE W.H.O.
AND ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED IN
CHINA.
I ASKED HIM DIRECTLY THE
INFORMATION YOU AND I HAD
DISCUSSED EARLIER TODAY.
HE DIDN’T GO DOWN THE ROAD OF A
CONCRETE ANSWER BUT HE DID
SUGGEST THAT HE IS LOOKING AT
THAT AND IT IS BECOMING
SOMETHING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REALLY WANTS TO KNOW
A WHOLE LOT MORE ABOUT.
>> Bret: OBVIOUSLY CHINA HAS
PUSHED BACK ABOUT THIS LINE, THE
W.H.O. CAME OUT PUBLICLY CAME
OUT AND SAID THEY WERE
DISAPPOINTED IN THE U.S.
DECISION BUT THE PRESIDENT
APPEARS TO BE WARMING UP TO THIS
LINE OF THINKING AND REALLY THE
ORIGINS OF THIS VIRUS HAD BECOME
A BIG, BIG STORY IF IT ALL PANS
OUT AS THESE SOURCES ARE SAYING.
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT AND THAT’S WHY I ASKED THE
PRESIDENT THE FOLLOW-UP BECAUSE
HE SPEAKS TO PRESIDENT XI -- I
ASKED THE PRESIDENT IF ANY THE
CONVERSATIONS HE HAS HAD IN
RECENT MONTHS WITH PRESIDENT XI
OR EVEN GOING BACK A COUPLE OF
YEARS -- THERE IS THIS REPORTING
THAT WE HAVE CONFIRMED NOW THAT
OFFICIALS FROM THE U.S. EMBASSY
IN BEIJING VISITED THIS VIROLOGY
LAB AND WERE CONCERNED ENOUGH
ABOUT A LACK OF SAFETY PROTOCOLS
THERE THAT THEY CABLED BACK TO
THE STATE DEPARTMENT THAT
SOMETHING SHOULD HAPPEN ON THIS
FRONT TO TIGHTEN UP THEIR
SECURITY PROTOCOLS.
THAT’S WHY I ASKED THE PRESIDENT
IF HE EVER SPOKE TO PRESIDENT XI
ABOUT THAT IN THE PRESIDENT SAID
I’M NOT GOING TO TELL YOU WHAT I
TALKED TO HIM ABOUT IN REGARD TO